[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day we're
gonna talk about a new study that says
that teens prefer texting to talking
goodbye to the $5 footlong but first
check out this story this comes to us
from Canada where a University of
Calgary student named Carlos dropped up
woman off who he met at a bar
she gave him a number it turned out to
be a fake number but he remembered that
her name was Nicole so he messaged using
the university directory all of the 247
women named Nicole at the University
they all ended up forming a friend group
show that next slide Gillian so they're
all got a Facebook group now they're
having fun but then in a surprise twist
show the next slide it turned out that
that that woman actually accidentally
gave him the wrong number and through
this entire is anything they've now met
up and the one the one thing that he
remembered about her besides that her
name was Nicole was that she was from
Holland and that she thought Nietzsche
was depressing is this is this a tale of
modern romance is this how we have to
meet people now or should should he have
taken the hint that she gave him the
wrong number what do we should have
taken the hit well then she should have
emailed every Carlos in Canada which is
going to be a lot easier to find he
obviously felt like she meant to give
him the right number if they had this
connection and they talked a lot every
man feels like they should I don't think
it's one in the college - Carlos is in
Canada are you the one I met no if you
didn't text her she would think he just
doesn't like her so I wouldn't do that a
girl be like I've got I've given guys
our number and they've never texted me
so it's like I'm not gonna search the
world but if someone gave me their
number and I might try to reach out a
different way I think we're just letting
this guy be insane I've done like
this before
I've done a couple of Miss connections
on I really but one of them was recently
we I was at the Frankie cosmic yeah
girlfriend before that and she like went
in like we were outside the concert
finish and we were like talking a lot
and she's like oh I love freakin cats
but I was like yeah oh my god cool then
she can't went in to see this venue and
then she came out and see me again she
like hung around for a sec and I was
like all right cool
see ya and I didn't do anything about it
and I post about it I saw her later
actually but I freaked out and then I
ran away that's what you think so you
think this is sweet because you think
sometimes I in college my number was two
digits away from my mom's number and I
made out this guy at a party
and I gave him my mom's number so he
texted her hey it's Trevor smiley fit
yes no I just I was drunk and gave him
my mom's number because it's two digits
away so he texted my mom hey it's Trevor
smiley face then follow up tag no I had
a good time last night
Oh a smiley face again and my mom never
said anything because you know you don't
go stuff I mean did you learn I ran into
him and he goes so thanks for texting me
back and I was like he never texted me
and then you showed me the number I'm
like that went through to my mom and I
just started right up
[Applause]
yeah so and I did want him to text me
speaking of phone calls a new survey
came out from common sense media that
found teens prefer texting to talking
face-to-face then social media so is
this the harbinger of doom or does this
just mean a new fun way for people to
communicate and we'll just see more
things like the University of Calgary
you know I'm wondering how did they do
this survey like did they do it through
talking or through texting it was a male
survey to over a thousand thirteen to
seventeen
okaywell teens eight males I do agree I
don't like to really talk too much I
like a text or text like six people
Texan would be the worst thing that's
gonna be a show you might hear that
would be awful hey we've got one more
story I want to talk about put it that
headline up Gillian subway is saying
goodbye to it's a long time five dollar
footlong deal they started this back in
2008 so now the CEO is saying that it's
up to the individual franchise if they
want to keep doing this deal or not
states rights are you I think it's fine
if you got like shitty margins which I
watched the shark tank once so and the
profit so I know that it's not running
successful business you got to take a
look at your margins your margins are
poor then you start to look at your
product oh and then see if you can
increase your sales and lots of
commercial
Mark Cuban I think what we need to do
can $5 footlong regulate the price of
the party sub Oh tell me how much the
party sub is make that 8-foot party sub
yeah baby
one of those things party game night no
one's gonna come and I mean your party
sub to myself you're almost always upset
this is like the first thing that brings
a light into your it's like I think we
can add so it's like lily and grace and
now party so this is beautiful in a good
mood I just want to keep this going you
have a shout out but I sure do and this
is actually a very nice shout out a nice
comment nan des original said watch this
in my school's library and literally
laughed out loud to the last part I
believe it was something that chris said
did I repeat the joke again Jordan do
you happen it's not working give it up
you have to be like a Comedy Central had
a show called Captain Marvel well that
was fun next up is a video of learnin
and Eden burnin which is learning and
burnin in Scotland please enjoy
[Music]
I am Ryan Beckett I'm a lucky dummy from
Missouri I've never been out of the
United States and Johnny here is my new
Scottish best friend and about to give
me all this and tell me what it is and I
hope I don't bother
so all this collectively as a scrunch
gran-gran
which is our local word for food right
which is an anagram of sultanas currants
reasons and nuts so local Cullen skink
like a sexy clam chowder here we go
no good Scottish breakfast yeah this is
black food in a good old hangs big beans
this is all my cod really good Cod this
is good old homemade peanut bar to me it
was tiny bit of Szechuan chili then last
but not least as our lethal egg
literally a boiled egg caught in haggis
what is haggis
it's everything that isn't used from
traditional cuts of meat all bombed up
traditionally haggis is then encased in
the intestine and then boils that sounds
so gross hmm you might give it a go and
then you can spit out through the way
that's what I say another day yeah I
mean after all of that you have to have
the water of life the water of lives
what whiskey means and gallons water of
life so this one is do not happen gonna
happen right here we go this is also
amazing but now I have to eat as much as
I possibly can and assume it while you
teach me things about Scotland okay I'll
take my time
how's that that's great right talk very
slowly right so start off with whisky
start with whisky that's the water of
life okay you know the national animal
right it's the unicorn it was the only
animal that had the ability to tame the
English lion local fact of the game of
golf the year 17:44 the rules of golf
for paned right here
right all right more beer more beer doli
the Sheep you have Austin but you have
to find cus for coning so that was there
1997's so the other weird Scottish five
there's 1772 we are the people that
drove on the left-hand side of the road
first you guys he's dead to be dead all
right
are you done I think I'm done no you
quiz me if I don't get him right you're
gonna have some more whatever all right
so what is this collectively known this
lovely food scram
there we go what does it stand for
saltines soap Thanos will give you it
current raisins a nut here we go fight
one war is our gallant meaning of
whiskey water a lot there we go what's a
war national animal unicorn horny and
why cuz it can English wine beat the
English line in there you go Corning
what was the name of the first cloned
sheep dolly oh here we go
how are ya tricky one even for me spell
[Laughter]
haha I think you almost got right but
the spelling was a little bit off so I
got one last gift for you honest what a
[Music]
great they made me do it
I've been back
here we go that was learning in that in
Vernon a chai you son-of-a-bitch apple
pie that's not Apple come on
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you I'm kicking off my first
round of the weekend by cheering all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink cheers to you Elon Musk for
smoking weed on Joe Rogan's podcast
proving that no amount of money can
protect you from getting roped into
doing your less successful friends
podcast cheers to you Jews need for
replacing Heidi Klum on Project Runway
this is like when Pepsi made a new label
they're practically identical and still
make me feel fat cheers to you cardi B
for throwing your shoe at Nicki Minaj I
think it's great you're donating to the
less fortunate
cheers to you Kanye West for saying that
Kim Kardashian is attending law school
hopefully she teaches you about the
right to remain silent
am i right cheers
[Music]